okay there's disturbing new video from
inside the Hard Rock Hotel in New
Orleans purportedly shot two days before
part of it collapse it was uncovered by
our New Orleans affiliate wwl officials
say three people were killed when a
large section of the under construction
hotel collapsed on Saturday the video
shot by a worker claims to show flaws
inside the construction site now it's in
Spanish and in Spanish she says
sarcastically look the best engineering
look at these large stretches between
supports and beams they're already to
the point of breaking he goes on to say
look at how it's already bent bent
already rather they couldn't remove it
because it's too bent and it has too
much pressure he ends by saying this is
seriously bad a spokesman for the
project contractor cautioned against
drawing any conclusions from the video
we reached out to the Hard Rock Hotel
regarding the video we have not
immediately oh you're right you can't
draw conclusions but something tells me
that's going to end up in a courtroom
yeah you can't but you can't say it's
unusual for a worker to go through and
say I'm worried they're just at the
Empire State Building and we marveled at
the construction a building that was
constructed in 1931 that has stood the
test of time yeah and here we are
struggling to build in 2019